oh you know people this is the Rubin
report I'm Dave Rubin and we have to
time returning champion from riot dot
org
Molly Swenson and one of our old-timers
she's back we flew her back in we have a
big budget and we flew it was first
class first class you can tell the
private jet all the way gen Hoffman and
we've got a lot to get to so let's do it
you guys may have watched the State of
the Union last night and was I thought
it was actually pretty decent especially
on the domestic stuff pretty decent the
foreign policy stuff was kind of all
made up and then there was a nice little
you know kumbaya thing at the end so
let's watch a little bit and then we'll
get into it and I commit to every
Republican here tonight but I will not
only seek out your ideas I will seek to
work with you to make this country
stronger
because
because I want this chamber I want this
city to reflect the truth that for all
our blind spots and shortcomings we are
people with the strength and generosity
of spirit to bridge divides to unite in
common effort to help our neighbors
whether down the street or on the other
side of the world
all right work together I like that when
he clasped the hands he kind of leans in
and whispers I feel like if I had a 3d
TV he would be kissing me but you know
all right struck a nice decent tone work
together mm-hmm this is Washington
that's just words right right so there's
a difference between a good speech and
an effective speech and I think this was
just kind of a speech that was meant to
be effective enough to let everyone know
that he's still hanging in there he
still has a plan but not to define
exactly what it is at some point he
defined his goals for the country as
broad right that speech was just a broad
speech it's he's not trying to deliver
the Gettysburg Address here he's just
trying to say something that doesn't
really piss off either side of the aisle
so he could say he's trying to work with
everyone so it was a good speech but he
didn't really say anything besides
generalization so that's pretty much how
I feel that most of these things at this
point they're just speeches they're just
a lot of words partisanship now you know
I get it the Republicans don't want to
work with him he doesn't really want to
work with them you could argue which
side is more to blame and all that but
do you feel moved by any of these things
at this point because it's nice all that
stuff was nice and it it goes to our
better parts right but do you feel moved
when you hear that stuff yeah well two
things I mean I think for one I I
disagree I think he does actually truly
deep down want to work with the
Republicans I mean he can say that and
mean it because it's not gonna happen
anyway right like the way the political
system is set up right so that actually
gives him more of a yeah I used to say
it in a way that's actually longer with
that and said look I'm trying to work
with you but I wish you know he could've
talked to you talked about gridlock a
little bit but he couldn't emphasize
that a little more the speech was a
little more peaceful and a little bit
more look he's ending the homestretch so
he can kind of set it out there like hey
I'm trying to work let's do it together
but
playing a lot of old hits right like and
that would those are the ones getting
the most applause anyway right it was he
was playing a bunch of old tunes and
likes talking about working together and
yeah using a lot of great rhetoric that
we loved him form that we elected him
for and without any potential
repercussions for that because there's
nothing else that he can really
accomplish with a Senate and the
Congress that aren't on his side
rhetorical instead of actually calling
to action saying he was like I'm willing
to work with you I'm willing to do it
basically it was like an open door
policy boss or manager at work like hey
any ideas you guys have just feel free
to come to me I'm open to her cool guy
boss and instead of saying I would like
to get things done just because I'm
coming to the end of this term doesn't
mean that you could stop me down for
another two years shutting down the
government won't work any more gridlock
and you know it's all gonna happen you
know the Republicans are gonna stop down
these things anyway and shut him down
but I think he could have called them
out a lot stronger but I think about it
like if that was a CEO who had a four
year tenure and then had to get
reelected into CEO and then was two
years into his last couple years he'd be
looking for very quick things and be
focusing on primarily the optics of his
leadership right not on getting things
done within that two years yeah do you
guys think it's interesting the way he
tries to appear to be above the
political system Inouye while he's
obviously very much in it you know he is
the head of the Democratic Party but he
does a lot of this lofty stuff that's
that to me is the disconnect but like
he's dying all this stuff and I get it
and but it's not six years ago like
that's what I kept thinking the whole
speech I was like wow six years ago we
were all in love with this guy the whole
country like it seems like we were all
on drugs we all we want and then we
didn't really get that it's not that
President Obama's done that he has done
so much so when people you know say that
he hasn't done anything as a leader I
don't know I'm not I'm not [ __ ] on
the guy I think it goes back to what you
said I think you perfectly articulated
it when you said that a CEO in his home
stretch isn't gonna try to rattle any
cages he's just gonna point out the
things that he's done and try to make
sure that looks like he's had a good
year exactly but this is a person who
has you said Oh got elected on hope and
chains and shaking it up and making sure
that we're all you know it was almost
like the shock and awe of campaigning
basically with him yeah I understand how
politically what he did strategically
would be the right thing to do in a
state of a union address however just
like you were
saying it doesn't match what his
political manifesto was to continue to
be above the fray of being a politician
right so go ahead oh no I'm just gonna
say I mean I think so I mean I've worked
in the White House when the first
midterm elections happened and they were
devastating despite everyone being
really optimistic about it and what
became so ultimately clear from being
there is that regardless of the rhetoric
and how good his intentions are and how
hard workers there are and how
passionate the people are who work for
him because my god there were some of
the most incredible people I've ever
worked with there's no there are no
incentives for the Republican Party to
let any wins occur within this
presidency bipartisan especially because
if they do then no Republicans will
continue to get elected and that's
worst-case scenario right become the
country fox right and especially now
because knowing that he's a lame duck at
this point now there's really no
incentive because now you want to take
him that if you're a Republican you want
to take him down take care so keeping
his legacy intact is the most important
thing that it still does again go to
what you're saying that if he's supposed
to do if he's supposed to really be that
leader that he says he wouldn't just
play the political and play out the
political scenario we expect right so do
you think speaking of the the midterm
thing so I think one of his lasting
legacies is gonna be that the Democrats
got crushed in both off-year elections
happens I mean it happens when there's a
Republican right but doesn't it seem it
seems particularly weird with this guy
like everyone hates the Republicans yet
seemingly everyone hates the Republicans
yeah they got crushed just at
expectations really higher I think
that's the that's sort of a critical the
critical realization is that like he
said expectations so high there was no
possible way to hit them Yeah right like
you go into a relationship being like
I'm gonna be the best [ __ ] girlfriend
you have ever ever had and you like [ __ ]
up once or twice it's gonna be
devastating as opposed to being like you
know I'm not that great at these things
and sandbagging a little bit and then
just blowing away everyone yeah final
thought on this do you guys think there
were two separate things so I thought
all the middle-class stuff was good the
insurance stuff like all the taxing
stuff I basically am on board with all
that's how I sounded good but the farm
policy stuff which he just kind of
skimmed over in like two minutes and
isel's on the retreat just this morning
I saw Joe Biden
talking about how we need troops on the
ground he sort of let it slip out of his
mouth because we're not on retreat I
feel like that's where he's really kind
of screwed like Europe's a freaking mess
right now the Middle East is a total
mess
so that part I thought just didn't jive
with the truth yeah the other part I
thought was pretty good well they spent
a lot of time talking in these you know
anecdotal stories of anecdotal evidence
about how the country is doing well you
know you know just kind of a joke
plumber almost type approach of talking
about you know so-and-so is health
insurance and so and so now can afford
to feed her kids yeah which is great but
it was a little bit more glazed over and
kind of its dreadlocks its storyboarded
like a clarity commercial or something
rather than talking about the fact that
you know we have like serious terror
threats or anything he was like well you
know let's just give some talks about
what somebody in the Midwest possibly
can do to buy a loaf of bread yeah
that's funny I want to know what the
side effects are at the end what do you
think of the farmer policy stuff look I
think there's a really inherent tension
for liberals when it comes to foreign
policy stuff and especially the hard
foreign policy stuff right now
terrorists disaster Muslim states what
do we do about that because on the one
hand as a liberal you're taught freedom
of religion and freedom of cultural
expression so important the most
important thing everyone's different
that's fine and on the other hand you
have to also protect freedom of speech
and civil rights and human rights and
when there's a religion and not everyone
in the religion and certainly not every
country that is a Muslim country but
hundreds of millions yeah you know
perpetrating these things that that
cross those lines how do you address
that right and how do you do it in a way
that is sensitive and PC and sort of
pansy and also
right so what yes so what do you think
the answer is because that's we talk
about this a lot on the show like as a
liberal I have to stand for liberal
principles that's what Bill Maher says I
totally agree with that and yet I don't
want to push what I believe on everybody
yet there's some seriously fucked-up
[ __ ] we're gonna which we're gonna talk
about later in the show going on over
there so that's why I think he's sort of
caught that's why that part didn't jive
right with me yeah it's it's just the
part of being president that I can't
even fathom having to make decisions on
right like I can fathom making decisions
on education policy and on any pretty
much I need to master domestic policy
right I I can fathom that I live here I
see these people walking down the street
I've always lived in big cities like
that make sense to me but just because
what happen it doesn't doesn't mean that
the leader of the free world shouldn't
be able to not only
but address it baby you sure sure I just
can't necessarily fault him for any of
the the decisions that he's had to make
given how smart the people are
surrounded in a weird way it's almost
like two separate jobs like you should
be President domestically and that
someone else should be in charge of the
farm policy stuff anyway we shall see
how the next two years go
big moment I guess at the State of the
Union last night was a slight heckling
and response moment by the president
let's take a look I have no more
campaigns to run my only agenda I know
because I won both of them
[Applause]
all right so I wanted to play out some
of the applause and then his response
and then the smile after because that
was sort of to me like the best of Obama
actually like he said something the
Republicans went in for the subtle like
I we don't like you and then he nailed
them and then you know everybody
everybody was into it it's a good comedy
move it almost struck me his response
was so quick and so clever that just
from doing comedy it almost struck me
that maybe this was a plant like was
that a Democrat who did that who did
that applause there it did seem to me
like that was either rehearsed or
planned out but he's such a pro at this
point and he's so good at articulating
things when they're kind of just funny
and off-the-cuff that I think it worked
I mean that was the thing that was in my
Twitter feed the most
you know everything else he talked about
people did not care about all you saw
was like Obama drops the microphone with
this quip so obviously it worked for him
yeah was the irony of that moment though
him saying I don't have to run anymore
so I can try to work with you and we can
do the best we can in these two years
and then the Republicans who assuming it
was a Republican that applauded that
they immediately were like I you're out
of here [ __ ] and then that he
immediately came back like it actually
showed the real problem of Washington
while I think what he was trying to do
was take the high road in this case you
know and then it immediately devolved
into aa potentially I mean I was
watching that and being like that's
adorable and ya know leader of the free
world probably wants to be called
adorable adorable little year I let the
energies just like yeah he looks so good
I yeah I I mean I had already a gaffe on
national television talking about how
much I love this president so I'm not
gonna like that there was an American
Idol thing that happened a while back
pre riot but no I think exactly about
him so very likable and very
performative when he gets up there right
as a as a performer myself and as
someone who appreciates excellent
performances I think that there that's
something that I'll always remember as
being particularly special about him
yeah the same way that Clinton was to a
certain extent but even more so a little
bit yeah
so we talked about this a little bit in
the earlier segment but do you guys
think that anyone in the next let's say
20 years is ever
gonna run on anything as exciting as his
first run because as I said I'm at like
it seems like we were collectively on
drugs and now it's like you're right
he's such a pro and every time even if
I'm frustrated with it you know he said
the thing like last night about net
neutrality and he wants the Internet to
be free but he also appointed Tom
wheeler who was a lobbyist for the FCC
to be in charge of it so that's the time
he kept talking about fundraising but
meanwhile how many $32,000 are played
fund raisers as he's done and yet so
he's saying one thing and yet he says it
in a way and or it's in a way that I'm
like each time I keep I keep buying it
for a little bit for a couple of days
after so is that like I feel like the
next president I suppose is gonna have
to be somebody that it's all about
policy like I think the country is gonna
be tired of just a well-spoken guy how
was that was that even a question I
don't know what I did that but i think
it's i think the way all those things
just came out of you is like the exact
same way that all the thoughts are in
our head we're all like wait do we want
another charismatic leader that's gonna
make us all feel good that we get really
excited and he rallies his base but also
the other side or do we want someone who
comes in and actually gets things done
yeah what's unfortunate is that you
can't get people to vote for somebody
who's just policy policy policy because
if they said exactly what they're going
to do right or they did it not only
would the other side whether it's
Republicans or Democrats oppose them so
much that they couldn't get it done yeah
but then they wouldn't be exciting no
one wants to get excited about someone
that's like no one gets excited about
the accountant or the bean-counter or
you know someone who's actually the
lawmaker people get excited about the
charismatic leader of the world yeah so
I totally buy that go ahead here's what
I think we get excited about the first
female run administration right like
that's gonna be the next one where
people are gonna be like hell yes and
you know maybe it's radical maybe it's
not but I think that you know as I try
and build sort of a female heavy media
company as myself yeah there's gonna be
a moment where people are like oh [ __ ]
yes like gender diverse organizations do
run better including the federal
government and like when there's a woman
at the helm it's gonna be I think it's
gonna be incredible and I think we're
gonna see maybe not the first woman
who's president but maybe the second one
right incredible amounts of progress
made what's interesting about the women
that are running is that Hillary Clinton
and let's say Elizabeth Warren were to
run are both very policy heavy driven
women both of them have certain
personalities that are slightly strong
and maybe could be considered
charismatic
they're not the men like let's say you
were running against a Marco Rubio are
running against some of those or Chris
Christie those are more personality
driven charismatic leaders the women
that are could possibly be leaving those
with warns and hillary clinton's are
very policy driven this is what we're
gonna get done I don't know the Matic
woman could win a presidency right now
really right I don't know I would like
to say yes but I think there needs to be
someone sear a woman serious woman first
to pave the way for women general yeah a
woman can't do jazz hands the way a man
his way to the White House right now
right so is that the irony then with
Elizabeth Warren and Hillary is that
those seem to me to be by far the best
two candidates even though I don't like
the idea of a Clinton legacy or a
Clinton kingship or whatever those seem
to be the best two Democrats but it's
gonna be two women at the top fighting
each other which actually could hurt the
women and then some guy just comes in
and it's an exit how do you feel about
that lady I don't think it's gonna be
like that I don't think it's gonna split
them I'm not worried about splitting the
vote so much as its setting a stage and
a precedent for women to be up there in
those debates and for women to have a
place there I would I would be fine with
both of them if it split the votes that
would be a really unfortunate byproduct
of that but yeah having two women I
don't think we can argue as a net
negative yeah all right you probably
didn't hear about this in the mainstream
media but Isis had a huge rally in Gaza
yesterday that was sort of co-sponsored
or at least allowed by Hamas and the
interesting thing about this is that it
was just barely a month ago that France
voted for a Palestinian state at the
Security Council at the UN so you'd
think that maybe the people of Gaza
would be a little more sympathetic to
what's going on in France with the
shooting and the Charlie Hebdo thing and
all that but that doesn't appear to be
let's take look
they're gonna get bad mr. Mitchell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so this appears to be the
first sort of big isis rally in gaza so
yeah they're burning french flags
this is the same country that voted with
them at the Security Council now I get
it they're upset about the the cartoon
thing but this seems extremely
short-sighted not that these guys really
have like a long do they have meetings
where they've sort of lay out how are we
gonna do this guys and what looks like
this just looks so terrible for them I
just it's hard to understand what the
goal is here like the most terrible
thing that's happened to behead two
Japanese citizens right now like judge
be a little bit worse than burning the
French flag when I look at this it makes
it appeals to the worst senses in me it
makes me become this xenophobic kook it
makes me become like an old drunk uncle
at Thanksgiving who's like burn them off
the map because just like what you were
saying is you're like okay so we just
told you you you can be in gods that we
the French supported you the French are
giving you a lot more depression voted
you or a state at the UN Security about
you yeah and now you're like well now
we're gonna burn your flag so it's just
like basically sometimes when I look at
this I'm like this is like when you you
have family members there's me they just
need a hobby like there it's like they
have nothing they have no real
information they have nothing better to
do they get pissed off they burn a flag
it sounds like so simple but I'm just so
tired of watching people that just
contradict themselves and just want
violence and to burn a flag and to
complain it's just it's like just stop
bitching go away and I'm becoming the
xenophobic crazy person I don't blow
them off the map when I look at it I
understand why people get that ignorant
inclination to go oh just [ __ ] them
right so how much of this not even in a
weird way not that I'm gonna defend Isis
at all but in a weird way that this is
actually Hamas is fault because nobody
can speak about them right you're not
allowed to speak about them so then the
people rally to make to attack France
because it's their only way of getting
out some frustration like the people of
Gaza their frustration in my opinion
should be with Hamas maybe with Israel
there's no logical thought here these
are people it's like lizard brain
mentality where wherever there's a
certain urge or a thought you just rush
to be angry or happy or excited or mad
whatever just pops into your head this
isn't critical thinking skills this
isn't well-thought-out plans of people
this is a population of people that have
nothing reacting well I just can't
decide if it's an inconsistency or if
it's just something that I can't at all
in any way empathize with that like oh
no freedom of press no freedom of speech
no freedom for women for gays for
whatever like all that's fine but like
don't make fun of the Prophet right or
you know anything goes that is like and
that as the highest priority honor to
defend I can't relate to right I can't I
can't relate to right so and this goes
to what we were talking about earlier
during the State of the Union part but
you want to empathize with these people
and then there's that disconnect there
yes yeah so we have a quote from one of
the protesters and I thought it kind of
just sums up the whole damn thing just
pretty perfectly today we are telling
France and world countries that while
Islam orders us to respect all religions
it also orders us to punish and kill
those who assault and offend Islam's
Prophet Mohammed I added a little
cartoonish reading there but doesn't
that get to it right there like on one
hand we're supposed to respect you but
also if you don't respect us the way we
want to be respected we will kill you
this is an absolute contradiction and
there's no way you can deal with people
that even in their official statements
about things directly contradict
themselves and I understand that
Americans contradict ourselves all the
time birth and practice and theory of
what we do but you have it right they're
like oh we're supposed to respect you
but you know if you do anything to piss
us off we're gonna literally kill you
yeah but like yes that also exists in
every other major religion like they're
our age right now and there's not you
know a lot of Jews running around and I
think this is just a Muslim problem with
this little sect of people who decided
to take Islam extremely seriously and
literally are contradicting their own
belief so it doesn't there's there right
so there's what we're going to kill you
so there is look Christianity did a lot
of bad [ __ ] and went through its
Reformation so it's on the other side of
that now and all religions do all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] but there is a difference
turn on Family Guy every episode has
Jesus there's an episode where Jesus is
literally sponge bathing with sexy music
playing in the background porn music as
Stewie's watching the Fox Network we're
airing out like they did with Charlie
about exact
so what do we now again it's not what do
we do about it but what are they
supposed to do about it over there I
guess is the question
well for one Hamas could stop saying
that Isis isn't their problem and that
they're not related to Isis and that
well they sanction this thing so there
they were like okay like yes protesting
France is like understandable whereas
basic human rights why not yeah all
religions have their hypocrisy that way
that's the same thing as Christians
saying that they're very peaceful but
then you know bombing an abortion clinic
and those are extreme examples I know
that's not the norm
but then it does take the rest of the
the middle of the population like if I
if somebody who claims under the name of
Christianity that there's no people
shouldn't have abortions ago bombs the
clinic people are like whoa whoa that
has nothing to do with us that person is
crazy and misters up representing us and
I think the problem is that most people
want to hear that from more Muslims but
it's also not their responsibility to go
around apologizing for their whole
religion so right there's really no
answer there except for what I said in
the beginning which is just [ __ ] those
guys
look people about they're killing people
and beheading people if you're beheading
people and you're burning French flags
and what else go [ __ ] yourself that
right there sorry so pretty awful images
have come out I mean we could do this
literally I could do eight clips on this
every week but some more awful images
came out of what Isis is doing in Iraq
and in Syria and this time it involves
the gays surprise surprise
so we've got a couple images for you
here let's take a look so this is Isis
throwing gay men to death or at least
men that are accused of being gay in
Nineveh Iraq so they're literally just
publicly executing them by throwing them
off the roofs of buildings and this has
happened before this is just a couple
pictures of it the third photo that
we've got here this is two men were
charged with thievery and bound to
crucifixes
victims are commonly crucified sometimes
after they've been killed in Isis public
executions by the way I should mention
that are our allies Saudi Arabia does
stuff similar to this and what you're
looking at right now is Isis stoning a
woman to death
for allegedly committing adultery all
right so we've done a whole bunch on
this and it just sort of never seems to
stop as Jen mentioned in the earlier
segment they've got two Japanese
hostages right now that they're
threatening to behead unless Japan gives
them two hundred million dollars should
any of this surprise us at this point
what actually before I even ask you that
shouldn't the gays be in an uproar right
now why why haven't I heard HRC or GLAAD
or you know when when Russia was doing
this we're not even going this far but
with Russia with Russia it was that they
were having vodka that supposedly did
not support it you know by the way that
Stoli vodka which was made in laughs
what's that yeah I was on the show when
we were actually wait a minute it's not
even made in Russia yeah that's the buy
if you can support something like I'm
not gonna drink you're certain brand of
vodka or I'm gonna boycott your Olympics
that's a lot more it seems I got my
Ratan jeweled goal than this
overwhelming seemingly endless stream of
violence coming from this region I mean
to go up against the country that we're
gonna engage in the Olympics with is
very different than engaging with
countries that are throwing people off
of buildings for being gay I just think
it seems so hard and so difficult so you
can't wrap your head around it like is
this real life right so when Isis gets
in the Olympics then we'll figure out
how to deal with them properly and what
would we boycott of Isis no but I think
that's a good point that it seems like
such an overwhelming daunting task
there's no way to even cook like in ten
country ten Muslim countries right now
you can be killed just for being gay
like that's actually law like they're
not breaking any laws right there so
like when you're trying to take on
institutionally multiple countries I
don't know that the HRC like I can do
anything right right I don't know that
they can do anything it just seemed odd
to me that you never hear GLAAD saying
anything about this or HRC hey they're
gonna go oh your whole country not only
does it believe and you know in very
anti-gay policies such as I don't know
killing people for being gay and stoning
women to death but it's just everything
on a whole level it's nice what they'll
cut up your hand for stealing so I think
that you think well I'm not even gonna
touch that if I'm glad because where do
you even begin you feel like you're
talking to a sect of people that are
just barbaric and not reasonable and
what do they give a [ __ ] of GLAAD issues
a press I know I guess it would be more
for us I think god no of course it would
be more for us they're not gonna go oh
[ __ ] you know
things that they feel like they can
actually change so if there's a policy
in the United States or in a country
that we are actually actively doing
business with it is worth their time
because you can actually enact change
and see something happen where if you're
wasting your time in that section of the
world where the the world leaders of all
the major countries can't even figure
out what to do
I think GLAAD is like oh let's deal with
stuff that we can actually do and I
think there's it goes back to the point
that you brought up which is like why
aren't there more people coming from
that part of the world to sort of be a
little bit apologetic for it yeah right
like watching it there they just threw
something out the building to a crowd of
people that are just watching there's
nobody in the crowd surrounding it where
they're saying will be thrown off the
roof too so there's an inherent problem
there like I think there are probably
plenty of people especially ones that at
least have internet access that want to
do something but they're standing out
there in the crowd guys guys please
don't throw the gay guy off the roof
well then next thing you know you got
thrown off the roof - yeah well they the
power numbers a little crowd could just
turn their back and simply not watch I
understand that's not happening right
I'm saying the way you have to enact
change there on the ground is not again
through issuing a press release do some
organization in the United States who
condemns you because over there it's
chill to throw someone off a roof for
being gay yeah that's a whole mentality
ship that's not gonna change just
through complaining or boycotting and
then as you were saying there's no
product to boycott they're not even
trying to salvo or host some sort of
international sporting position too much
about glad I do you think we have some
like real like cognitive disconnect
between like how we live and what's
going on in the rest of the world
because no matter how many of these
stories we do and no matter how many
times you see it it's seriously hard to
believe that this I mean I think I have
a cognitive disconnect like 500 miles
inland right like I've never lived
anywhere off the coast so I guess far be
it for me to say that like I can even
identify with someone in the Bible Belt
right you can't let a little Allah let
alone this I can't make it out of it
yeah yeah I think there's a complete
cognitivist nickim pleat lack of empathy
but what's also so fascinating is that
with the birth of social media and all
this we're more connected than we've
ever been we have the ability to see
stuff that's happening in real time
across the world and that's a very
recent development so like we will see I
think we
see people you know the Arab Spring was
the start of it people actually rising
up against whatever that they thought
was was wrong and I think we will start
to see this once people are introduced
to to other cultures right like this is
what the the tenants of the Peace Corps
was created on right when kennedy
created the Peace Corps there were three
tenets of it one was you know go and and
help this far-off culture the second was
you know maybe teach them something
about American culture and teach them
about you and the third and what he
always thought was the most important
was bring that story back and try and
create empathy here because you
experienced something that none of your
friends and family have yeah to him that
was always the most important so to that
point you know I give America a lot of
[ __ ] and the whole reason I'm doing the
show is I want this country to be better
but I've started to think in the last
like two months or so as these videos
constantly come out and as we see all
the stuff that's going on in Europe and
free speech and xenophobia and the
headings and everything that's happening
all over lists that maybe we need to
take a little moment to realize that
things are actually pretty good here not
to say we have we've got racial problems
we've got problems with bullies we got
it denying it right every day we get it
we get it we talk all about that what do
you think we don't as Americans like
just take a moment to be like you know
what it's actually pretty good first
world problems and those are like third
world problems where your basic human
rights are violated and not even
considered forget violated they're not
you don't even you don't even have any
basic human rights let alone civil
rights higher level rights exactly they
don't really have that so I understand
it it's okay to address first world
problems you know if you're having a
trouble with your cable company provider
it's all relevant so it's not like
you're like oh well I don't want heat or
I don't want access to whatever it is
you feel like everybody attacks that's
because there's beheadings in other
countries and people getting thrown off
stuff but it does make you go wow we do
comparatively have it have you been
feeling something similar to that yeah
absolutely I mean I think that any
opportunity you have to sort of get
outside of yourself and realize how
fortunate you are you take that right
like whether that's all in tearing or
whether that's traveling or whether
that's you know even just like going
down to skid row right and and taking a
walk around anything that makes you
realize how how fortunate you are is a
but but in the case of I mean in the
case of this I think it's so it's a
tough right I think that you have to you
have to just look on the side of like
compassion and peace always and I'm like
the hippie and me is like come on like
that's not bomb anyone and let's not do
anything let's just like travel and
experience this and see what happens
from that human connection we met
someone you're less likely to go bomb
them right when you've met someone
you're less likely to bomb them there
you go all right so we all know the term
metrosexuals that straight guys that
dress sort of like gay guys then we did
a story about two months ago on Spore no
sexuals these are also straight guys we
are now taking this to the next level
with all the shirtless selfies and show
it off muscles and tattoos blah blah
blah now there's been an interesting
discussion going on on reddit about high
sexuals and these are straight guys
supposedly straight guys who when they
smoke weed they become temporarily gay
yeah that's right and we've got a quote
from reddit this is from one of the high
sectionals he says I feel very attracted
to girls and not at all to men when
sober and when I get high I just want a
big [ __ ] to suck and a man who [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of me doesn't not that it
really bothers me since I'm still
attracted to girls while high but
sometimes I feel weirded by male friends
with whom I don't usually feel attracted
to so I thought this was kinda
interesting cuz I've never heard of this
before you know people get drunk like I
guess pardon there's a couple things
going on here so first of it
experimentation is more accepted for
girls right dude version of a girl being
like while I was in college and we drink
tequila the me made out and I don't know
how to really like girls but women are
kind of pretty when I'm drunk so like
that's this is the dude
reddit version of that so Rafic dude
yeah girls don't get that graphic with
it yeah is that partly here is this just
that guys are far more repressed
especially straight guys are far more
repressed about their sexuality so in a
weird way these guys get high and it's
like it's just giving them like 5% well
that guy seems to be wanting more than
5% but finds that it's it's not just
high it's you know if you get drunk if
you're on LSD if you're on ecstasy
whatever like
the more you experiment presumably if
your sexuality is already something
you're struggling with or not but it's
repressed yeah that's gonna allow it to
come out or manifest itself in some way
yeah I think people just need a label
for everything to that so I think that
in sexuality which most people know is a
gray area just from our fantasies
whether they leaned towards heterosexual
or homosexual all of our or everything
in between fantasies are still
inherently gray and we keep them to
ourselves but once you can label them
like oh I'm into bondage or oh that's
very Fifty Shades of Grey once we give
it this sort of label like high sexual
now you finally can understand why
you're having these thoughts dude
something and identify with someone else
who experience exactly so if your duty
and you've been having some thoughts
towards other men that are a little bit
sexual and they happen to get a little
bit stronger when you're loosened up and
a little bit high well now you have a
label for it it's high sexual so now
it's more acceptable because you found
another group of people or other people
that can identify with you and it's
really just human nature
is do you guys think that the next sort
of evolution of our sexuality now that
the gay thing I think is pretty much
behind us no pun intended like I think
basically that's pretty much out of the
way and the Supreme Court is probably
gonna finish it off in June that the
point is that that do you guys think
that straight guy's sexuality is the
next thing that's going to evolve a
little bit like a couple friends the
other day about why a threesome with two
guys and a girl is called a devil's
threesome like why I ever heard that
book I had neither and apparently it's a
thing and I was like well you can
clearly a guy came up with that term the
three of us have ever heard of the
devil's threesome that's clearly another
label to make it okay to do it because I
feel like all three of us are liberal
enough and you know sexually educated
enough were I mean we probably know
about stuff like the donkey punch and
the dirty sanchez and we talked about
the devil devil's threesome so that's
clearly another label to justify yeah
but yeah you realize that 90% of our
viewers just pause this to go Google
dunk don't I don't do it I guess
you lost everybody do you think when you
combine gay and weed that this is like
the right-wingers nightmare like because
this is what they fear they fear partly
that that straight Pete or that gays are
turning yeah and then that we now you
throw a weed into it too and you've got
this a lot they do a lot of meat for
them right lose their own control well I
feel like if you're so worried about
marijuana turning you gay then that
means that you are afraid that there's
some part of you that would really like
to be gay once you've become high on
this crazy devil's threesome
anybody who's conservatives nightmare
because conservative is a lot is about
control and is a lot about denying these
urges because you've chosen to take the
higher path and Road so to them this is
you know the worst-case scenario is
you're gonna hand that weed Nebraska
Delia this is complete hedonism
unfettered and yeah so final thought on
this if they could prove actually that
weed makes you a little gay does that
help or hurt the gays do you think if
they found out they if you smoke weed
you can get temporarily gay you have a
gay old time with your friends I think
that it would hurt it it would hurt it
because here's the thing is the strength
of the argument for gay rights is that
it's this inherent thing that you have
no control over and no say over cuz why
on earth would anyone choose to be gay
if they could be straight
what's that argument just for the record
real quick like that argument even like
that cuz I don't think anything's wrong
with it so it may be right that
convenience it's not as convenient as
being straight yeah you know presumably
not yes but I think that if if there if
there's ever a choice element then that
makes the plight much harder because
it'll just be assumed that if you can
switch back to being straight you will
at some point and that the legislation
doesn't exist for someone who chooses to
dye their hair blonde and it doesn't do
doesn't choose to you know exercise or
whatever that might be but if there's
some inherent trait that's making you a
certain way you should be afforded the
same sort of rights as everyone else so
I guess final thought would be if we had
the old-fashioned threesome the two girl
one guy three what would that be called
fun that's just a good old
like everyone should not gonna believe
this but it turns out that good
old-fashioned laziness is more deadly
than obesity that's right the University
of Cambridge did a study over the course
of 12 years where they talked to 300,000
Europeans about their habits now we've
got some of the findings the greatest
risk of an early death was in those
classed as inactive and that was
consistent in normal weight overweight
and obese people simply walking for
about 20 minutes a day can reduce the
possibility of an early death by 16 to
30 percent and we've got a couple more
findings for you a person runs a higher
risk of an early death by being
moderately thin and inactive whereas an
overweight or obese person who exercises
regularly can actually be more fit than
the same person who thinks that they are
already fit because of their physical
stature okay that was a lot of words now
we got this from riot Oregon we have
someone from riot org so rip into this
thing for me laziness versus obesity oh
I think this is problematic for me I
haven't worked out in like nine months I
have this false illusion of health
because I like can't gain weight to save
my life but um no I think that this is
it makes a lot of sense right and it's
the same sort of potentially
mind-blowing moment that you know
William Julius Wilson created in the 70s
where he was like actually the biggest
defining factor in your life out coming
where you end up is your socio-economic
class and not your race and it's like
correlative versus causal and all that
and yeah it makes sense that like more
people who are fat tend to be inactive
also right but it's not the obesity that
is killing them it's the inactivity your
blood your your heart's not getting any
exercise you're dying from heart failure
earlier you're you know whatever getting
clogged and the Bloods not flowing it
makes a lot of sense I think that that's
just sort of a maybe a good news to
anyone who is a little bit overweight
and who can't shed those pounds but who
is actually pretty active like you're
you're safe yeah you know I was thinking
when I was reading this that actually
laziness is sometimes good because I
think we live in a world where we just
never stop I think for me like my
inability to stop looking at my phone
doing all that like that's like my brain
needs some more laziness I know
not directly yeah related to this but I
think a little laziness and shutting
down and letting your body kind of heal
itself of all that must be pretty good
right yeah there's two types of people
that haven't even met each other like on
earth basically and those are the people
that can't stop it's like the can't stop
won't stop
always busy very active trying to
achieve and then there's a lot of people
that really do nothing there's people
that report that they spend hours and
hours a day what watching television are
playing video games are doing any of
these kind of like my number and like
sort of kind of pleasure activities that
when you do nothing and I think it's
really do game people are gonna be
pissed at you well that's right I'm
gonna say that they're working on their
eyes you're judging it either way yeah I
don't necessarily know or we're
necessarily say it's better to be a go
go go go get her all the time it was
just I'm not judging your cider saying
it's better I'm just saying that it's
funny when you say like isn't a little
bit of laziness good of course that
would come from somebody who's
consistently busy and just wishes a
break but meanwhile there's probably a
lot of people that are you know doing
nothing and chilling that it would
benefit them a lot to go for that
20-minute walk that it says right there
and it would make a lot of sense also
that people you know we is we're very
visually driven Society so when you see
somebody who's thin you assume that
they're healthy when you see somebody
who's overweight you've seen they're
unhealthy obviously somebody was really
fat probably is not as healthy as they
should be for the study makes a lot of
sense I mean that's where they get the
term skinny fat - yeah you know it's
funny I mentioned this a couple weeks
ago but what was the movie I saw in her
skin with Scarlett Johansson I think did
you guys see it it was this random
sci-fi movie she did about three years
ago and in it she's a little more
overweight and by that I mean she's
skinnier than 99% earth but there's a
lot of scenes complete nudity 100%
nudity and you can see she she has some
curves looks like a real woman and I
remember watching thinking she actually
looks healthy and I never see that yummy
I personally look healthier when I'm a
few pounds overweight when I look five
pounds under I look way less healthy I
look gaunt and I am actually physically
less healthy and I think with women in
particular I know that wasn't the topic
here but women with fertility and with
health usually tend to actually read
healthier in tests when they have it
what we would consider an extra five to
ten pounds much more than the extra than
less five or ten pounds which is what
seems to be the value right and I when I
was watching movie I was thinking how
[ __ ] up it is actually that I'm
thinking that because maybe she looks
like two pounds overweight
see all the time that you know it may
actually be that she just didn't have a
tan right like for me my weight doesn't
write in my tan I look way healthier I
like way more muscular I looked yeah
yeah alright so getting back to this
thing though how much of this do you
think has to do purely with what you
were hitting on which is television like
I can't imagine before television what
people if you were lazy now you just
watch TV on a Saturday you could watch
TV for 10 hours a day on any day you
watch TV for 10 hours a day but before
TV did people just what did they do that
you know find a way to be lazy stare TV
you probably the type of person that
would have sit and stared and watch the
door
I guess the obese people before there
were television yeah so it's sort of do
which came first but I think it was
probably the TV yeah alright stop
watching TV don't stop watching YouTube
though and let us know what you think in
the comments right down below an
interesting study came out of Holland
and you're not gonna believe this but it
is true
women do cry more than men and we've got
some info for you men cry for an average
of 2 to 3 minutes compared to 6 minutes
for women men are less likely to
experience extreme crying that's the big
waterworks the hysterics that you see on
the TV they're all the time
females are more likely to cry for more
than an hour while females cry between
30 to 60 4 times a year
men only cry between 6 to 17 times per
year so we've got a quote from ayodhya
who is the editor of girl talk she says
I think if the media had a more balanced
perspective on human emotions and didn't
pigeonhole women and men perhaps the
survey would have different results
there aren't enough emotional males on
television or in the media for men to
relate to there's a segregated view of
what is accepted as masculine and
feminine in the media it's because of
the media so I think that's actually a
pretty sound argument right there there
may be some genetic or biological or
evolutionary reasons as well no Molly
you're not with me you think you think
this is purely just kind of the way
media frames things men have to be
strong you can't see men crying but you
can see that yeah yeah I mean I don't
think that there's any really solid
proof that like women's tear ducts are
shallower or that like we're just more
emotionally unstable naturally I swear
right the there's two social things at
play here one is that this entire study
is self-reported right so like it's
self-reported
are gonna be more comfortable admitting
that they cry more right in addition the
fact they probably do cry more because
of social constructs like that and I
think that ahsha's point is great and
Asha is amazing as a person and a really
really intelligent woman who has great
things to say about everything but she I
think hits on something really really
really prescient which is that men even
still in the media and we're in 2015 and
we have a black president and we have
you know all of these these things that
have evolved for us over the last couple
decades still there aren't really men
crying anywhere like American sniper or
there's a moment because you've just
killed however many people and you're
like having PTSD that's okay to cry
right oh no not like not very much the
only other thing I could think of a man
crying or at least not even in a movie
is John Boehner who does cry when he
gives speeches and you know he you know
when he's accepted things and awards and
things he gets very emotional and we all
make fun of him for it right or at least
all the comedian's do and then pretty
much everybody does and yet if it was a
woman we would think it was a tender
moment or something so that does go to
just our expectations right of men and
women that's at that moment where
Hillary Clinton finally got emotional
and everyone said that turned around her
you know ability to run as a
presidential candidate cuz we finally
saw like this math come down and saw her
have some emotions right when John
Boehner cries were like oh you [ __ ]
you know so he a little bit of a double
standard there but I mean it look I
think the biggest point is what you made
when you said think about self-reporting
that wasn't my first question was how
much do we trust self-reporting and rich
do we expect women are inherently more
okay with saying they pride and men are
more likely to disguise the fact that
they've cried so I think maybe this
statistics might be a little bit off on
this
that being said I'm telling you right
now I cry literally every day okay so
never cry everytime cry all right well I
want to know when the last time you two
cried and then I'll tell you mine so I
think we have yours already but
waterworks oh I want that tear has to be
coming out of guys not just teared up um
so I made this promise myself when I was
13 and I had had my first kiss and I
never called that I would never cry
about a guy again ever
and maybe it says something about my
life being like a little too blissful I
cry really about anything okay I cry in
movies sometimes the last time it was
like waterworks though I was on a plane
I'm like a plane movie watcher crier and
it doesn't matter what movie it is I
would like always tear up so it was like
seven dresses or PS I love you were like
some not even sad movie and I was crying
my eyes and it just got okay last I
cried this morning what were you crying
about this shoulder surgery on Monday
two days ago I had shoulder surgery and
I was trying to actually get dressed and
right now the arm hurts so much I'm
honestly not taking any painkillers
right now and try remain alert and
articulate bring a button-down shirt
today that I actually attempted to put
something on that wasn't to my arm came
completely out and it hurt so much that
I started to cry and then I got so
frustrated about it that it was an
emotional crime it wasn't a cry okay so
that that I think is really interesting
because a guy like I know if I if I stub
my toe or bash never hurt myself like I
wouldn't cry from that there would just
be that that emotion wouldn't be in the
little box of things that I would pull
out I'd be screaming and I'd be pissed
and angry but that but that so a girl
might cry for pain I usually actually
don't cry for pain I cried for the
frustration that's associated with the
pain so this morning even though my arm
hurts so much that's not why I was
crying I was crying so like god damn it
I can't get in this dress and I couldn't
but I'm hungry and I need coffee and
like this I feel like I cried for like
all of civilization and you know like I
cried for all things since the beginning
of time already five times today before
I got here is what I'm saying so it
didn't necessarily have to do the fact
that my arm hurt that was just a that
was just the you know what is it the
trigger hing thing that made me cry for
everything that's ever happened inside
of the moon yeah all right well I want
you to cry by the end of the segment so
I'll tell you - crying stories what my
last cry was about a year and a half ago
when my grandma was dying and we were
all saying goodbye to her on her
deathbed standard stuff and we actually
had a really beautiful moment and and I
cried the other one involves my other
grandma when she was dying this is about
five years ago and we knew that they
were gonna have to pull the plug and I
watched the movie click did you ever see
the Adam Sandler movie yeah quick so I
watched it thinking that it was going to
be like an over-the-top Adam Sandler
ridiculous comedy but if you watch the
movie it's actually pretty touching
basically movies that just [ __ ] with you
he gets this remote control where he
then skipped through and fast forwards
through his whole life and I was
watching that knowing that they were
about to pull the plug on my Graham
how fast life goes and all this and I I
mean lost for an hour like uncontrolled
could not stop that would be an
acceptable thing to self-report crying
about you know so that just kind of got
now I've cried over I've cried over the
last five Adam Sandler movies because
they're all terrible they're all
terrible yeah I think there's also like
something interesting happening to were
like yeah we're all movie like we cry at
movies all three of us here
has anyone cried about the genuine car
about Charlie Hebdo did anyone cry about
see that's things I cry about stuff
unrelated to meet you buddy that's
that's great I like about humanity
everyday which sounds like I'll just see
the news and all of a sudden just start
crying or I'll see something positive
and inspiring and Stark right I cry all
the time I have no problem saying that I
think what person with an iron will like
people are like you're a tough lady to
me so I I have no problem it's not like
I feel like oh I'm crying it makes me
some I don't care I cracked a lot
all right well Jen made it through this
segment without crying but are you
crying right now when's the last time
you cried let us know in comments right
down below new research from The Ohio
State University shows that selfie
takers chronic selfie takers you know
who you are are pretty much the most
narcissistic people on the planet that's
right they say people that overload the
internet with lots of selfies are more
likely to exhibit psychopathic or
narcissistic qualities that don't know
we've got some more info for you men who
reported taking extra time to edit
selfies with Photoshop or other programs
before posting them online also
exhibited high levels of self
objectification which means they liken
themselves to sex objects instead of
people a mode of thinking that can lead
to such problems as eating disorders and
depression I've talked about it a bunch
like I am so over the selfie thing I
hope that I hope that I can live up to
this that I've taken my last selfie
there might be a situation where I'm
alone and like an alien is there or
something and I got to do it but pretty
much we're all taking selfies while
there's other people there that could
potentially take the picture and usually
better I'm over the selfie I believe in
this narcissistic thing you know that
we're all staring our phones and then we
immediately wait for it to watch the
likes roll in and it's all crazy and
self-absorbed go I think it stems from a
certain amount of loneliness
most people when I see them posting
selfies I understand you're saying
sometimes there's other people that
could take the photo for them so if
you're in a public place and you're
taking selfie like at lay eye
tower and you're taking a selfie but
looked at also coming born of inherent
loneliness - you wanted other people to
see your experience and experience it
with you which is a little bit
narcissistic but at the same time you're
not interacting with other people to do
it so I know everyone likes to make fun
of people like oh they're taking selfies
but I always when I see someone posting
a lot of selfies I always want to reach
out and go like oh my god are you okay
need someone to talk to you Jeannie ah
yeah
you're it's like look at me help I like
I'm alone why don't you ever take a hike
with another person exactly maybe yeah I
think there are a handful of cases in
which a selfie is fine right if you had
Halloween makeup on great take a selfie
if you just got a crazy haircut and you
want to share it with the world and let
everyone know you did fine if you are
passing by the president's and it's
behind you take a selfie do that if
you're Ellen DeGeneres that the Oscars
and you're surrounded by 20 a listers
take it yeah I think the problem is when
people take it when there's nothing new
there's nothing new about their
situation they're at home you've already
posted 20 other selfies with their cats
like don't do another one there's
literally like no other more literal
display of narcissism than a selfie when
there's nothing to report as like
newsworthy that person you should call
them because that means they were
sitting if you know somebody in your
life that's chronically taking selfies
home alone in their house or just alone
I mean instead of this attitude where
people make fun of that person and be
like oh you're such a narcissist or so
you're so into yourself that really
makes me want to get in touch with that
person and be like because I mean maybe
I know what that's like if nothing
better than - you're like moles we'll
take a picture it's a way of reaching
out to the world and going this is a
reminder that my face still exists
please talk to me yes so I'm so on that
you know I post my boyfriend and fiance
guy I do some stuff with he he's an
incredible chef incredible chef so I'm
constantly taking pictures of his food
and then I do some X Pro - and a little
highlights or whatever it is and I'm
constantly doing it and then and I
realized how silly it is it's like
instead of immediately I get the meal in
front of me of my first inclination is
to take the picture now he's working on
like a book about it so we're trying to
do something with some of the pictures
but removing that like you know it's all
taking us out of the experience you guys
find that when you're doing this that no
one's sort of living through everything
I was just in Times Square and there
were literally people with the selfie
stick have you seen this thing I mean
there are people that are just walking
the selfie stick in front of them
staring up and you know people that are
clearly from other countries that have
never been there before in Times Square
I think again there's exceptions to that
rule right if it's something that you
created like a creation of yours food
art whatever it might be like take a
picture of it I don't know if it's like
you're out at a restaurant someone else
made it for you for no other reason then
you want to show everyone what you're
eating like again a bit narcissistic
that people would care but but yeah I
mean I I was always a chronic picture
taker like I would I had the newest
digital camera always and I would just
you know obsessively take pictures when
I was out with friends now I have like
ten thousand photos in my iPhoto there
like some of the most incriminating
stuff ever we'll never be able to get
elected to any public office because of
the pictures that I took out okay that's
gonna get confiscated at some point I'm
sure but I think that there's I don't
think it takes you out of the experience
because then you can go back and relive
it and with better memories of it than
if maybe you had just been experiencing
it with one set of senses yeah all right
what do you think
are you a chronic selfie taker are you
taking selfies right now while watching
is if you take a selfie while watching
this and then tweeted at me I will
retweet you and then I'll feel better
about myself you'll feel better about
yourself
etc etc let us know in the comments
right down below you're not gonna
believe this but a new study has found
that married people are actually happier
if you watch sitcoms that doesn't seem
to be the case but yeah
a study there was a study on it let's
take a look this was reported in the New
York Times being married makes people
happier and more satisfied with their
lives than those who remain single those
who consider their spouse or partner to
be their best friend get about twice as
much life satisfaction from marriage as
others people have the capacity to
increase their happiness levels by
finding support in long-term
relationships so I thought this was kind
of interesting because first off yeah
everything in TV seems to show married
people miserable right they're always
miserable the guy wants to go have fun
and he's just a goofball and the woman's
overbearing and wants to ruin his day
and we've also done tons of stories on
how Millennials and people mostly
younger than us don't even want to get
married they're getting married much
later now in their 30s there's very few
people getting married in their 20s so I
thought this kind of flips things
it's head for conventionalism so
historically in any of these studies
come out men report higher levels of
happiness when they're married across
all socio-economic barriers across all
races so we've already known for some
time that men report being happier when
they're married
maybe that's because they have somebody
to assist them in things somebody that
is take care of them they found perhaps
a mother and women report being less
happy they don't stay the same women are
unhappier right starting to shift a
little bit I think as we start to look
for more partners people in this New
York Times study that described
themselves happy while married also
tended to describe their relationship as
a friendship so to feel like you have
somebody who has your back and your peer
and is your equal of course that would
make somebody happy to have somebody was
constantly there for you and I think the
further you feel separated from your
partner when it's a relationship either
of convenience and the person is not
your friend you're going to be less
happy because that's more work right so
this friend relationship thing is kinda
interesting and it was making me think
of when Harry Met Sally the famous line
of how men and women just can't be
friends at least a straight man and a
straight woman can't be friends that's
issue with that yes please go ahead oh
no I just take issue with the notion
that men and women can't be friends that
sexual tension is always going to get in
the way that is just not the case I have
so many guy friends my boyfriend would
disagree but I'm not friends with them
if the guy is like yeah we're friends
but I would totally bang you then you're
not just I don't like overwhelms the
interaction every time that we have like
you know a meal or see each other it's
like genuine friendship that goes beyond
the physical attraction I I think
entirely yeah I do think that there's
also something to be said for two things
one maturity right you get to be more
mature and I think you ultimately find
that you're willing to sacrifice the
amplitude of an unpredictability of
relationships and dating for something
that's more consistent maybe you never
get to the same highs as when you're
dating and you're infatuated and you're
falling for someone but you never have
to deal with the lows of breakups and
you know other devastating things that
happen when you're when you're doing
that right that the contentment level
may never reach here but at least it's
never reaching here and you're just
there and when you will get to a point
where you just wanna put up the [ __ ]
anymore you're gonna be happy that you
found that right and I would guess that
for
many married couples the happiness level
does get there too because there's all
kinds of other rewards that they can get
together either through having children
or doing whatever that you know a single
person maybe can't download well this
study seems to closely match like
Maslow's period pyramid it seems that
once you are able to be self actualized
in your life like you're not searching
for food or shelter it wants your
socio-economic bracket is such that you
can search for self-actualization and
happiness you tend to find partners that
you can also be friends with it's not
just a matter of survival and finding
someone to not only procreate with but
just put the rent with and if you look
at this New York Times study that
actually is reflected in this so that
people that have a little bit more means
a little more flexibility in their lives
tend to report that they're happier but
only when the relationship was at the
point where this wasn't out of necessity
but they've chosen this relationship and
it's not you know scrambling to be with
somebody right alright so last night on
this do you think part of it also is
that it just doesn't seem cool to be
like oh I'm married and happy like when
you say that it just doesn't seem cool
as versus like I'm single I can do
whatever the hell I want I can do drugs
and go out what like they said there's a
cool factor there so people this is
always greener elements yeah though and
I think that you know more and more
people are whether or not they're
married if they're in sort of a
long-term partnership you you see that
as very unavailable if you're in a
short-term partnership that's maybe
rocky or if you're single I think that
there's there's certainly something
enviable and that and free one wants to
strive for that yeah ultimately are you
single and want people to think you're
in a relationship well there is an app
for that that's right there's actually
two apps for that there is invisible
boyfriend
an invisible girlfriend and basically
this will fake it for you on social
media and people will think you're in a
relationship boy what can technology do
we've got a little more info for you the
app generates believable photos of your
pretend partner by soliciting selfies
from ordinary people as opposed to using
posed looking stock images the service
is $24.99 includes a hundred texts 10
voicemails and one handwritten note they
are hoping to expand into countries
where it's a crime to be gay and people
might have an extra pressing need to
fake a heterosexual relationship so
we'll get to the gay thing in a second
but the idea that they're gonna you know
there's gonna be voicemails a
handwritten note text messages so it's
not just social media it's actually
stuff that
it's beyond that like it's like oh look
you know you mean not just I'm not just
putting this stuff out there we're
faking pictures but also like this is
intimate stuff like this is like mom
look I have text messages from this
person what has the world come to you
know we're catfishing ourselves I mean I
understand it to an extent I think that
when you see so much social media out
there of oh this is me my boyfriend this
is our perfect relationship and you know
and you go home for whether it's a
holiday and your parents are asking like
oh why don't you have a boyfriend or you
know you're at work and other people
receive flowers there's just basically
people are looking for ways to show that
they too have it all that they're happy
and this is a way for people to do it I
mean I feel you know sad and my heart
goes out to anybody who's like lonely
enough to want to fake a relationship to
show it to other people but I also
understand it because there's so much
pressure to show everyone that you know
you're involved in these things right
and having girls sort of done this for a
long time like girls have done the thing
where you understand yourself flowers
the office just you know oh yeah I guess
yeah we've got a couple images from the
website which we can roll through as
were as we continue to talk here what do
you make so there you go I think so I
think they're gonna have a tough time
scaling this right to keep that same
level of personalization if you're new
handwritten notes and knock it not make
it seem really inauthentic yeah you're
tough time scaling so it may be that
they get to a point this is wishful
thinking where they feel like they have
a responsibility to vet the folks that
are coming to them right for yeah right
but if they did that could be an
interesting pivot to the model right
we're like they're doing it to really
fulfill a need for the way they talked
about it someone who you know who lives
in the Bible Belt their grandparents
don't want them to know that they're gay
or there's a stalker at work or
somewhere like there there are true use
cases for it that could be really
beneficial to society but if it became
this rampant crazy thing it's just like
you know we're getting into this weird
territory it's like her and like
catfishing ourselves and like where does
reality end and I'm super into this
whole Machiavellian take two
relationships I have never participated
in that but when I was reading through
this article I was like wow like there
are people that really do send
themselves flowers at work to make it
look like they're you know more
desirable or there's people that would
have somebody maybe text them or call
them while they're on
with someone else to make it look like
they have all these other suitors like
why did I never think of that I'm like
I'm super into this now I'm gonna be
googling the [ __ ] like office
manipulative psychological repercussions
yeah right it just seems like a lot of
work like the person that's sending
themselves flowers or even dealing with
this stuff and you get the handwritten
note like then you're showing it to
people that work than it used to be
because they do it all for you now right
that's right outsourcing it you're
outsourcing your own weird narcissistic
sad lonely you don't need to show people
that you have somebody else but I then I
feel sad say next I know there's people
watching this that are thinking well
this could be a good idea for me and I
don't even want to judge those people
because maybe it's a good idea for you
to use this right and actually you gave
a couple of good examples of why it
could be good and of course the gay
thing especially in countries where it's
not legal or you could get in some sort
of trouble by having a fake front while
you actually live your life on the side
I suppose it's fine but I was thinking
this could be good for Jan Brady because
remember Jan Brady never had a boyfriend
and then she invented George class yes
that's what I'm saying I'm super into
this whole inventing someone thing in
just the psychology behind it and what I
understand was that we're doing extreme
examples we were talking about how if
you live in the Bible Belt and your
family you know is concerned that you're
gay and you want to prove that you're
not which also opens up a whole nother
can of worms if should you stand by who
you are or should you invent somebody
just out of fire but you're doubling
down on the second leg exactly and then
what we were getting into what they say
that they're one of their end games is
is creating profiles for people that are
in countries where maybe you could
actually be thrown off of the top of
something for being gay I mean this
could be a really helpful tool for
people at the same time but right now it
just sounds like entertaining and fun I
would make up a fake boyfriend right now
all right if you want to be a real
boyfriend for Jen Hoffman comment right
down below Molly you've got a boyfriend
right - so yeah she doesn't need this
app sorry but thank you to two of them
their twitter is or write down below
thanks for watching comment like all
that good stuff and we'll see you next
week
[Music]